I have begun by wanting to talk about
these angles in a concise way okay so
I'm trying to prove similarity here I'm
looking for a triangle ABC this big one
around the edge and I want to compare it
to triangle ACD this smaller one in here
okay now tell me not a rhetorical
question what jumps out at you they're
both isosceles triangles
yeah they're both isosceles triangles so
that makes it easy to work with they're
similar
so therefore probably angles is the
easiest way to go because when you're
getting to the reasoning all you need to
say is equiangular rather than the ratio
of the blah blah blah is in purported
that's that's long I try to save time
here okay and I'd have some information
that angles so I'm gonna call this guy
over here Phi just to go along with
Athena okay if that's fine where I'm
gonna go straight to is therefore in
this small triangle I'm gonna go to a CD
you see that up there right a CD up
there is also equal to fire here's the
way that I said it you can talk about my
sources training with you I but I will
say a CD equals fire and my reason is
equal angles opposite equal sides now
just before I finished this reason the
reason I'm saying it this way is because
I know that ABC is isosceles because
they've actually told me but in the
question they haven't actually told me
that AC D is isosceles I can see that it
is but nowhere in the question does it
actually state it what the question does
say is that there are equal sides see
that hey hey that's given you see it's a
small nuance you're gonna lose a mark
over it probably not but I think this is
a more accurate way to say it like I
want to use less information not more
okay speaking of that triangle like I'm
about to say the same thing but about a
different triangle and there's one two
three triangles at least here so I'm
going to say that's
that triangle okay you happy with that
I'm going to say this also let's let me
get to the it's worth it's worth coming
back to that point how about I get to
the end of this similary pretty long and
then I will address the wider question
of similarly because we will get to that
as an exercise and it's worth saying a
few things about it okay where are we
okay so I have a bunch of angles right
this is all I need
I've got all of the pieces in place now
so I'm interested in these two triangles
ABC and ACD equi angularity is the
easiest proof to do I just need two
angles two pairs of angles I should says
right C ad the one I started with is
common it's in both triangles C ad is
comment okay and then I just went to
prove this right so I can say a CD is
equal to a B C I just showed you why
okay two pairs of angles therefore
similar
and of course my reason is equiangular
sorry that's a bit messy okay now here
is where our pause to make a note in
answer to your question about like okay
like how do I actually say like what
what kinds of things do I put in here
what's gonna close this you okay in
triangles
we've got similarity we've got Congress
right similarity chords and they're
really like you know brothers okay
for Congress there are four proofs right
for proof for Congress is just one s s s
give me another one yes yes I can't put
RHS Hyup
I want to follow a pattern here so I'm
going from sides
angles okay point six four ways to prove
congruence if you haven't already
spotted in it there are four ways to
prove similarity and they are exactly
the same think about it okay SSS what
you need is and I'm going to use the
abbreviation but I'm going to say what
it is okay I want three sides in
proportion rather than no radical
similarity is easier isn't it SAS right
because it's you know right so the point
is the angle is between the two sides
right so you've got two sides in
proportion and you've got the included
angle right the one in between it has to
be in between otherwise you're an ass
right and you can make us two triangles
which have pesticides and reports and
the angles elsewhere and they're not
similar
it must be included what's this
similarity prove the corresponds to this
- English it's just to English of course
it's just to anglers what you've got -
you had the third what's what the side
does is locked in the size of the
triangle right of course this one it's
got the exact same thing except the long
he's worried things okay now just a
quick note right and see if you can
answer in terms of the three principles
I gave you this morning
why is it that here three letters are
fine yes and over here you've got to
write an essay why it's not a rhetorical
question come on you can think of why
okay okay so you have to make it clear
right I want to say SSS three sides well
fine when you say SS here it's like what
about the three sides there is something
specific a piece of information a
quality of the triangle that you haven't
said anything about namely their
proportionality so that's why there's
words here sentences and he letters of
fun okay
all right are you happy with my
similarity proof that okay all right
yeah I I did this just so I didn't have
to say so many angles that's why I
introduced by or X or whatever or these
ratios so yeah I mean it's if it's clear
if it's clear